ciao ragazzi bentornato in una puntata
di cucina buttata oggi faremo una delle
cose che dall'inizio di questo format
io sogno di potervi riproporre solamente
che prima bisogna ovviamente fare delle
cose un pochino più famose è arrivato
però il momento di fare una ricetta che
tra parentesi neppure è stata
consigliata un paio di volte pure più di
un paio di volte perché là fuori e
pietro intenditori mica come questi due
che me l'hanno sconsigliato in tutti i
modi sto parlando dei moti giapponesi si
è abituato tutto questo suono però
comunque che cosa sono i modi poi ci
sono questi dolcetti di questi fagottini
di una pasta di riso un pochino gommosi
na ripieni solitamente di marmellate
varie confetture ora io ricordo viene in
mente quella ai fagioli che fanno i
giapponesi fatti sono gli unici dolci
giapponesi che fanno scoraggiare una
variante di cui io sono innamorato
follemente e quella dei magi ripieni in
realtà di gelato oggi faremo dei moti
alla vaniglia ma la cosa che
potrete utilizzare il gelato che
preferite quanto sono figo che oggi sto
continuando a guardare a sinistra ea
destra come se fosse in tv per faremo ci
avevamo bisogno di amido di mais
zucchero acqua magico questo è vitale ho
fatto un pochino di ricerche ho visto
che in italia suggeriscono spesso di
utilizzare delle farine che io
sinceramente non ho ancora compreso tipo
di riso glutinoso ora non so se siano
non la stessa cosa ha fatto sta che
quando vedi in video alcune ricette demo
ci quello che tu vedi è una roba
giallastra in realtà dovrebbe essere
color
come dice in maniera
color perla un liquidino perlato e
infine gelato alla vaniglia
lui è la prima cosa che bisogna fare è
creare l'interno una maniglia deliziosa
che altro scusate ragazzi che brutto da
vedere in camera che c'è tutto questo
capito che straborda anticipazione è
vero come si chiama gelato alla vaniglia
biologico san marco è un elefante sono
molti altri prima cosa prendiamo un
vassoio e li mettiamo sopra tono secco
innanzitutto vorrei ringraziare amy made
in japan perché è la ricetta che noi
stiamo seguendo usciranno enormi che
buono
no è una palla di gelato vada buttarli
in freezer
facendo lo schifo cogliendo ma non come
autore giocatore va bene qual è la sila
buttare la scatola è arrivato il momento
adesso di fare i moggi all'interno di
una ciotola che possa entrare nel
microonde con te che non mettiamo nelle
ronde una cosa drammatica da vanno bene
le ricette che non eri stufo in realtà
faremo c è semplice ma difficile di
questo magico io vi lascio il link per
comprarlo in descrizione è una farina di
riso dolce ed è quella che viene
utilizzata per fare gli starnuti potenze
per fare immo.c io non credo che altre
farine possano andare bene perché ho
visto veramente le immagini alla fine
facevano schifo
che cos'è morale 75 grammi di noci co
alla vostra così quanto impasto a quanti
musico non ne ho idea
per 33 è giusto che si ma abbiamo fatto
tre muci così 100 g di zucchero il mio
cibo il nocita lo zucchero e granulato
mentre invece il noci musicò è un po
tipo zucchero a velo 100 millilitri
d'acqua e riteniamo vedere che cosa
avremmo la fine arriva vicina dice un
centauro metà uomo metà sedia sbattiamo
a 600 watt per due minuti all'interno di
microonde per poi perché molti ragazzi
sì si può andare microonde questa due
minuti gianmarco quelle gambe da jack
skeleton
in realtà suggerisce di metterlo altri
30 secondi è uguale giusto quindi io
saltiamo non credo sia così
si è così grazie prendete l'amido di
mais e lo setacciate su un tagliere ha
[Musica]
messo niente aveva mandano avanti come
stranissimo al tatto lo raffreddiamo per
una trentina di minuti
allora uno dei tap il migliore
il grembiule speciale
avremo davanti questa sbuffa e dovremo
tagliare i quadratini con i quali
avvolge remo il noi prendiamo un
piattino li mettiamo sopra della
pellicola trasparente e tagliamo c'è
qualcosa che non mi torna
sarebbe bello in eccessi mettiamo
l'ultimo foglio di pellicola e aridaje
lasciamolo riposare altri 40 minuti che
è di la ricetta secolo però è come fare
la pizza tra la pizza è un attimo no
perché devi evitare logiche così male
aspettiamo il tempo passate al tempo a
tirare fuori il gelato dal freezer e i
foglietti dal frigo allora questo
acquisto è poco mezzo sciolto morto
braccio di cui dobbiamo essere veloci
perché l'estate sta arrivando e quindi
questi si scioglieranno in due secondi
passeremo un foglio afferriamo il gelato
e lo avvolgiamo per darmi una mano
consigliano di prendere la carta questa
qui in pizzicare i lembi in modo da
chiuderlo alla perfezione per i non
elevato adesso improvvisamente curioso
capisco che quando lo chef bravo di
mangiare in camera questo qui è il più
storto e di tutti preghiamo dio che
funzioni ragazzi indovinate un po che
cosa succede adesso infiliamo per
un'oretta in frigo ragazzi altri due
centrato
abbiamo aspettato una mezz'ora ragazzi
perché un ora e troppo
grazie all'arte ok quindi dovremmo
mangiare velocemente
inizia ad aprirla diciamo rimboccati
sotto diciamo il modo più bello è quello
liscio liscio liscio
sono un po licci un po mortizza di
assaggiarli loro pc così tagliato una
spiaggia bocca ben senso ripieno di del
gelato che hanno comprato più nessuno
attorno sinceramente non ho fatto niente
questo sono le funzioni di questa è una
ricetta giapponese caldo in bocca in
ipotermia
che succede è sta congelando
controllando i denti era giusta
sensazione un estraneo
non è un altro pezzo nomina era buona
in particolare nel fatto un impasto mai
assaggiato collina ragazzi dopo due
generazioni siamo riusciti ad
assaggiarli discreto sì esatto diciamo
che l'attesa non vale il risultato non
sono assolutamente accordo vi portino a
mangiare dei modi magari fatti ancora
più sento un leggero sapore di farina
che eccessivo ma c'è qualcosa di tipo
granuloso non c'era essere l'impasto
della tornerà vale come che le definito
prima per la pole a parlare è il colore
giustissimo il colore perfetto sono me
era un po troppo amido di mais farina
vabbè comunque siamo arrivati a piedi
questo video ragazzi fatemi sapere se
proverete anche come a fare questi
motivi ricordo che su instagram mi
diverto sempre a vedermi taggare
all'interno delle nostre stories nelle
vostre foto quando ci provate a fare
queste cose qui spesso i risultati sono
anche peggiori dei miei ragazzi
come sempre l'invito a iscrivervi a
questo canale se vi siete divertiti ad
attivare la campanellina delle notifiche
qua sotto per non perdere i prossimi
video noi come sempre ci vediamo la
prossima domenica alle 12 con una nuova
puntata de mita buttata ciao di cucina
buttata cucina mutata ciao e tutto
buttato qui anche il mio tempo